ANTHONY BUSHONG:
Today we're talking
about the future of data,
mosquitoes, and tick data
analytics.
I'm Anthony, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Numerous factors
underpin the challenges
of growing data volume,
including access and storage,
inconsistent tools, new and
evolving sources and formats,
compliance concerns, and
security considerations.
To help you identify and
solve these challenges,
we've created a new
whitepaper, "The future
of data will be unified,
flexible, and accessible,"
which explores many of the most
common reasons our customers
tell us they're choosing Google
Cloud to get the most out
of their data.
Mosquitoes aren't just the
peskiest creatures on Earth.
They infect more than
700 million people a year
with dangerous diseases, like
Zika, malaria, dengue fever,
and yellow fever.
Prevention is the
best protection,
and stopping mosquito
bites before they happen
is a critical step.
That's why Google
Cloud was honored
to team up with one of
the leading pest control
brands, OFF!, to
develop a new publicly
available predictive model
of when and where mosquito
populations are
emerging nationwide.
Learn more about the mosquito
forecast on the blog.
We just published the
blog post announcing
Google Cloud's latest
STAC-M3 benchmark results.
Following up on our 2018
STAC-M3 benchmark audit,
a redesigned Google
Cloud architecture
achieved significant
improvements-- up
to 18 times faster, up to
9 times higher throughput,
and more.
Read more about these
results and a whitepaper
on how we designed and
optimized the cluster
for API-driven cloud
resources on the blog.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.